on est bien que deux choses et mon amie
la rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis né baptisé ne rosé
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre émission
le petit émir pendant plusieurs mois
vous allez suivre toutes les étapes de
la création d'une pièce de théâtre par
une troupe de comédiens porteurs de
handicap
la pièce le petit émir écrite par marie
vaiana raconte l'histoire d'un homme
faisant le paris dakar qui va tomber en
panne dans le désert il va le rencontrer
au milieu des dunes le fameux petit émir
et va se laisser embarquer dans une
enquête initiatique qui va bouleverser
sa vie
tout au long de cette saison vous serez
en compagnie de marie qu'à la metteuse
en scène qui sera accompagné
d'éducateurs spécialisés comme
jean-michel ou daniel bonjour je
m'appelle marécages fait art thérapeute
à l'asfa l'association saint françois
d'affilée donc art-thérapeute sait
utiliser l'art au quotidien avec des
personnes en difficultés motrices ou
intellectuelles etc les aider à travers
l'art à se sentir mieux être mieux dans
leur peau et dans leurs baskets dans les
premiers épisodes
nous allons suivre marica lors des
castings dans différents ateliers de
l'isle qui vont lui permettre de former
la troupe du petit émir le premier
casting a lieu au collège
adrien cerneaux dans un atelier mime
vous y découvrirez adeline à d'aline
zidane paulo
lisa damien steve et tous leurs amis
certains feront ils partie de la troupe
finale
des habitués donc j interprète pour les
élèves de la ressource qui sont intégrés
ici au collège
donc on se dit bonjour avec les gestes
des enfants sourds ok bonjour ça va
après les présentations place l exercice
des masques qui doit permettre à chacun
de révéler sa véritable personnalité
la confiance est primordiale la
confiance en soi bien sûr mais aussi la
confiance dans les autres après les deux
premiers exercices plaçaient la
discipline reine l'hymne
donc là on est dans une phase de
repérage donc on va voir des différents
ateliers qui existe dans nos
établissements du mime du théâtre la
musique du chant la danse et dans ses
différents ateliers on va essayer de
repérer les jeunes d'un qu'on sent qu'il
ya des capacités et mais aussi on va
essayer de puiser dans ce qu'ils
proposent d'un des choses qu'on pourra
intégrer après au spectacle donc voilà
des détails ou des personnalités ou des
visages aussi qui nous semblent
intéressants à puiser à garder pour pour
ce spectacle petit aignan c'était donc
le premier épisode avec les collégiens
d'adrien cerneaux certain talent ont-ils
émerger marica at elle trouvé la perle
rare
vous le saurez en suivant les émissions
à venir
dans le prochain épisode nous
poursuivrons le casting à la maison
d'accueil spécialisée de sainte suzanne
à la recherche de nouveaux talents
à très bientôt